a woman she was oh a true inspiration to
all and I've got to say you know not
only as I said on the did she break the
ceiling she smashed through the glasses
but it was everything about her a great
friend to me great advisor in what way
you should pick up the phone and she'd
have them in the office and so if
somebody else answer the phone is that
you Helen no it's Joe well I don't want
you about Helen tell him I want dinner
with him tonight so I go along and said
you're doing a good job of it but it was
always the book being a bit Rowdy throw
one or two out she said Sean who's in
charge that's all you need to do and
just check what you're wearing I like
tradition so she was brilliant you know
everything about her she was still there
she was still a great friend still
giving me advice which was fantastic you
said you like but she didn't like the
wig all because she said of the good
head of verse she said that's why I
wasn't wearing that wig because I asked
her right away oh no she said why we're
on spot or sir instead I've got good
quality here she said I've got plenty of
it she said so I'm not going to wear
that wig so it's quite funny you know
and thankfully she took the decision not
for us to wear the wig so I'm forever
grateful for that
um from tiller girl to top politician
how did she make that transition
like everything tragically she got
injured when she was a tiller girl and
she took up politics and she was
unlooking lucky she was lucky to be
selected with so many by-elections and
then finally she brought through at West
Bromwich but she'd been around the labor
party she was the labor party she went
on to the NEC at a time when it was
quite strong between the left and the
right pulling back was a vote Betty was
in there doing that she was also an MEP
as well at the same time as being an MP
she did everything she was the party and
then suddenly she became Deputy speaker
and then as we know in 1992 she decided
to become speaker and she was brought in
as I say first woman speaker she brought
in welcome by everybody absolutely
fantastic in making history and from
there on as we know we went through the
Troubles of Ireland the peace agreement
she saw at the end of a major government
to the beginning of the blur gun you
know she went through it all and people
say you know there's always history she
was in the middle of making that history
she was from Yorkshire though well as I
always said to her this is the white
Rolls versus the red rolls of course the
red rolls always wins but we were always
United the north always joins together
yeah she was fantastic exactly we can
slug each other off but don't take us on
hold on
it's not yet
when did she start to step back and and
you know what was her life like in later
years
like everything she used to choose the
moment in which to speak to the media
she could have been on the media
constantly and she didn't do that she
waited for the most important time when
she felt it was right to speak out and
that's what she did should she pick a
moment she denture with the Lord she
will prepare that speech and done and
same with interviews she didn't want to
be constantly there far from it she
wanted the major moments where she felt
her advice were Belleville and a
reminder of what we should be doing do
you ever hear her voice when you're
trying to keep him under control oh
absolutely it's it's that loot lovey it
was always lovey and I love that you
know it's fantastic it's that bitter
Yorkshire isn't it you know that
dewsbury girl meets Charlie Langston lad
you know it was fantastic and and it's
the way that she used to say you're
doing a good job it's always that book
that gets me and of course when I'm in
the gym and I was thinking you know you
look at all of them I'm the 158 she was
the 155th speaker all that has to be
Forest but who do I loop back to I've
got to tell you it's better yeah no
today there's going to be quite a lot of
people that want to say lovely things
about her absolutely we've got another
hour of people paying what their
memories and it will be their memories
they'll be laughter there may be tears
but what we will be doing is united in
all of the thoughts of holding this one
it was a National Institution we're all
there for Betty and Betty was a person
of the people that's why she wasn't
Elizabeth she knew what she was doing
when she set off I'm Betty Betty Bruth
right even though she came baroness she
was still better to me and that's how
the public will remember and that's how
the chamber is going to remember it
today we're going to have some great
stories of those people who were there I
came in and she was in the chair and you
think oh my word who is this speaker you
know she kept you in order by just
looking at you and she was that kind of
fast emotion but she was generous with
it she was nice she held good order but
she was good fun with it so we'll hear
all those great stories today people be
queuing up to tell about how they got
either in trouble or work with Betty to
deliver a better chamber that's what she
did she get really good on it would he
be able to keep a dry eye no I've got to
say it when I found out the night before
on Sunday night it was sad and I've got
to say it upsetting I knew she wasn't
well in fact we just arranged for
flowers to be sent because we thought
she was coming home and we thought
everything was well and you know at that
age you know at some point we've all got
to depart but we were told that she was
getting better she was going home so we
thought everything was right and I'd
suddenly got the phone call and I've
just got to say it was sad to hear and I
will miss her I'll miss the advice
because she was always there she said
whenever you need me just give me a ring
she's that kind of person okay well
thank you for taking the time I'm sorry
if I upset you no no no no it's just
that we'll have a good day today
fantastic it's great to see you as
always thanks for coming in